how long did it take you to hack into
NASA not long there was a exploit that I
was leveraging in a database service
that like if you had a website that was
running on a Windows system there was a
msad c. dll it was a for data
connections but it was Dynamic link
library that was accessible from the
internet the problem is is the way that
it was configured out of the box is you
could send it shell commands and
basically issue commands to the box as
if you were sitting there if you had an
account on the machine and it would run
under the web user permissions a lot of
people when they were using this way of
defacing all they were doing is they
would Echo a text string to the index
page of the website so you would just
get this black and white screen that
said Shawn Ryan was here type
thing